welcome to this video playing soups
Cindy oops was my mouth my most Ruth
acting straightly simply Eve sandy sandy
from Brazil the English Defence again
yeah mighty 292 this is a tricky line
let's see guy wants to play a g3
normally but now I've provoked an early
you five let's see what happens now the
very a strange type of position h3
maybe five I need to need to really make
use of this night on g4 c5 is designed
to undermine me five blacks players
based a lot on on provocation if i take
here he needs to check with the with the
Queen they can take the night actually
forgot about that I had night age 6
which wasn't terrible maybe it would
have been terrible because of d5 and
yeah anyways okay 94 I have 95 this
should be okay I hope queen deform hmm I
need to move it of course probably to h6
or this one and this is what's
interesting probably what I would have
chosen what now knight c6 to a techie
five this is really exposed spawn so I
should try to attack it Wow cannot
believe in this really can you can
weaken yourself like that okay I'm
trying to open up the position as
quickly as possible try to to use this
Queen takes on hmm our Bishop takes yeah
okay come on take what the bishop should
be 3m oh what's now
is there some way to try to exploit this
g5 if it's a very powerful looking move
if it's good as another question it's
got night be five ragged mission before
trick then okay now also says it's
interesting if he takes bishop g three
years tries to make use of the weekend
kingside g3 opens up the bishop this
really cannot be right and this i forgot
that they only had looked at night b5 i
can give the check it's not it's not the
end of the world but it's not what I had
planned so if I check here
hmm
night to d6 our this is really a problem
and he's got Bishop g5 potentially
well yeah very very very tough position
oh the other sister I want to control g6
of course Bishop e7 I was my idea yeah
f4 looked really crazy to me just just
like utterly utterly insane but that it
didn't really didn't really turn out to
be a problem Queen takes covers the
sensitive squares I really thought that
this should be something that that I
should be able to punish but no way I
didn't I mean I didn't find anything
maybe there was nothing answer of course
possible I wonder about Queen f3m were
intending Queen to have six just just
drop back okay
and I want I really have a hard time to
understand this position the king is a
problem of course I don't know should I
should I exchange stuff or not this King
isn't isn't great as well I mean look
like 24 is certainly okay for me but
maybe this is better to keep keep pieces
on Queen to have six I thought yeah this
is hanging of course we take c5 this
queen of six very difficult position Wow
yeah this is some this is quite typical
for this this English Defence this be
sick smooth it leads to very tricky
dynamic positions
maybe you can take I didn't really
didn't really think about that but it
was a quick move I only thought well
let's get this on the G file g2 is
something that my bishop is of course
eyeing attending look G for all kinds of
stuff now and queen e three years also
not not bad maybe Queen f1 know okay
check if you fall now but it's got to
look look h3 in this this wacky move
hmm look in trim this got kawin everyone
the potential IDM yeah it's I don't have
enough time ready to figure this out I
don't think I'm worse at all but in the
Sun with this time it's difficult check
yeah this is not a not a very logical
move to be honest check check this is a
draw isn't it check this is the draw a
perpetual check
time warning check check
I think it's a drone check check check
no no no no I don't have a check can I
what the crap game just I hate this all
right black resigns yeah this is just
frustrating with them at the end to not
have to draw at least i'm pretty sure
that there were ways to to to get a
better position yeah Knight f3 here wins
instantly of course there okay okay
let's check if we look at this he needs
to take Bishop takes and looked you for
next it's gone I had seen this idea even
but not consider it it's right now the
problem was I didn't really am ok this
is also winning group chief or no wins
check I forgot about this resource this
is maybe this is the real problem I
forgot about that I thought now I just
played you for this was my idea but he's
got got the Smith and now I'm Jim it's
nothing nothing in particular check yeah
this is just a little check check check
but this isn't the wrong so neither
three is the wrong I do this here yeah I
thought it doesn't draw in any way yeah
this is this i need to do and and it's a
draw yeah besides all the winds before
this is what I should have done check
yes doesn't see me doesn't seem to be
enough here 22 is a draw again check
this is also draw check I forgot about
that I have
that he has got queen that he's got King
g6 of course check this is just suicide
suicide move ah alright thanks for
watching